übrigens solche fahrverbote bei
feinstaub alarm drohen demnächst auch in
münchen in köln in düsseldorf super
glückwunsch an alle bogen deutschen
diese käufer deutscher diese schau spaß
pur und in zukunft also entscheiden wie
leben in stuttgart oder in münchen oder
düsseldorf oder in öl oder in 80 anderen
zu gekürzten deutschen städten
endlich kein lässt die gefahr mehr
endlich können die die bundesliga
konferenz mit einem kalten bild gemessen
wurde die benutzten die casino statt und
wird das fahrverbot kommt auch dafür
findet sich eine lösung für immer kaufen
sie weiter unsere bibel recht jetzt
kaufen sie weiter diese lippe
red
[Applaus]